now I need to clarify this is running my
life you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there are two types of cards in this box
where cards which have people and social
media networks on them that you have to
post to and there are these what cards
which are the things that you have to
post or the things that you have to send
to people from the where cards post on
snapchat so now you all look through
your hands and you find something from
your hands that you want me to post on
snapchat if I go through with it I get
to keep this yellow card it's worth two
points and whoever's challenge I pick
gets to keep their black card which is
worth one point I'm obviously gonna do
who has experience escaping football so
I posted on my facebook has anyone
escaped a cult before and I've gotten a
lot of responses
[Music]
make someone private Facebook message
mission yeah okay what is this this is
real I don't know what this person is
but I'm freaked out
can I borrow some bucks I need to send
money overseas not a scam I'm doing that
[Music]
somebody commented and just tagged their
husband but like I don't know why
probably gonna send you money do you
know who the person is I went to Hebrew
school with her escaping a call if
you're genuinely looking I have a couple
of friends who did send someone you used
to be into so I have to send a photo of
me flexing to someone I used to like so
[Music]
I got a response oh you did okay so the
response wasn't pg-13 hi there my name
is Kevin and I'd like to be considered
for the position of babysitter it was
and I quote go [ __ ] yourself
oh so somebody doesn't need a babysitter
apparently I posted that photo of me in
the dark on Facebook and when I opened
up Facebook they had this alert about
who can see my post she's reminding me
that people necesita my nonsense of me
picking my nose
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]